alors que les etats-unis s'apprêtent à
célébrer c'est tragique anniversaire
oussama ben laden est réapparu dans une
vidéo la voix attribuée à ben laden
affirme que la bataille contre les
américains n'a pas encore commencé nora
boubetra c'est presque une balade
bucolique
sauf que le promeneur en question c'est
oussama ben laden l'homme le plus
recherché du monde devrait couvrir mais
ils marchent tranquillement
seul signe guerrier une kalachnikov la
mise en scène ne diffère que quelques
peu des anciennes vidéos un paysage
montagneux quelque part le chef du
réseau al qaïda est un homme fidèle une
fois de plus c'est à la chaîne
arabophone al jazeera qui livre son
visage petite nouveauté cependant
l'image n'a jamais été d'aussi bonne
qualité
quant au son il semble avoir été
enregistrées séparément pour une fois ce
n'est pas le numéro un qui parle mais
son compagnon de son bras droit
l'égyptien ayman al zaouahri affirme que
la bataille avec les américains n'a pas
encore commencé après dix sept mois
d'absence le responsable présumé les
attentats du 11 septembre se paye donc
le luxe d'une apparition avec son
lieutenant
ces images auraient été tournées favriel
début mai si cette vidéo comme les
autres restent difficiles à authentifier
elles permettent de certains aux
sympathisants du réseau terroriste de
rester en alerte donc la force d'al
qaïda actuellement c'est par un ses
messages ses appels au djihad entraîne
des réalisations
sur différents pays du monde où il n'est
pas nécessaire qu'ils un soutien
financier immédiat un soutien logistique
par fourniture d'explosifs immédiat ou
même des spécialistes entre guillemets
des experts d'al-qaïda qui se
déplaceraient sur place pour la
réalisation
la réalisation se fait par des réseaux
dormants qui s'activent au vu de ces
simples appels au djihad une nouvelle
cassette une de plus oussama ben laden
continue donc de vouloir entrer ses
ennemis comme un mauvais cauchemar au
moment où les états unis commémorent les
attaques du 11 septembre
[Musique]